Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to create a virtual world
with breathtakingly detailed pieces of geometry.
These are some results from a new technique,
and boy, are they amazing. I wonder how expensive
this will get. We’ll see about that in a moment.
Now, here , we wish to create a virtual world, and
we want this world to be convincing, therefore we
will need tons of high-resolution geometry, like
the ones you see from our previous episodes.
But all this detail in the geometry means tons of
data that has to be stored somewhere. Traditional
techniques allow us to crank up the detail in the
geometry, but there is a price to be paid for it.
And the price is that we need to throw more memory
and computation at the problem. The more we do,
the higher the resolution of the geometry
that we get. However, here comes the problem.
Ouch. Look. At higher-resolution levels, yes,
the price to be paid is getting a little steep.
Hundreds of megabytes of memory is quite steep
for just one object, but wait, it gets worse!
Oh, come on. Gigabytes? That is a little too
much. Imagine a scene with hundreds of these
objects laying around, no graphics
card has enough memory to do that.
This new technique helps us add small bumps and
ridges to these objects much more efficiently
than previous techniques. This opens up the
possibility for creating breathtakingly detailed
digital objects, where even the tiniest
imperfections on our armor can be seen. Okay,
that is wonderful. But let’s compare to how
previous techniques can deal with this problem
and see if this new one is any better.
Here is a traditional technique at its best,
when using 2 gigabytes of memory. That is quite
expensive. And here is the new technique. Hmm!
Look at that - this looks even better. Surely
this needs even more memory. How many gigabytes
does this need? Or, if not gigabytes, how many
hundreds of megabytes? What do you think? Please
let me know in the comments section. I’ll wait.
Thank you! I am super excited to see your guesses.
Now, hold on to your papers, because actually,
it’s not gigabytes. Not even hundreds
of megabytes. It is 34 megabytes.
That is a pittance for a piece of geometry
of this quality. This is insanity.
But wait, it gets better! We can even
dynamically change the displacements
on our models. Here is the workflow - we plug
this geometry into a light simulation program,
and we can change the geometry, the lighting
material properties, or even clone our object
many-many times, and it still runs interactively.
What about the noise in these images?
This is a light simulation technique called
path tracing, and the noise that you see
here slowly clears up over time as we simulate
the path of many more millions of light rays.
If we let it run for long enough, we end
up with a nearly perfect piece of geometry.
I wonder how the traditional
technique is able to perform
if it is also given the same memory
allowance? Well, let’s see…wow,
there is no contest here. Even for other cases, it
is not uncommon that the new technique can create
an equivalent, or better geometry quality
but use 50 times less memory to do that.
So from now on, we might get
more detailed virtual worlds
for cheaper. Sign me up right
now! What a time to be alive!
And, one more thing. When checking out the
talk for the paper, I saw this. Whoa…20 views.
20 people have seen this talk. Now, I always
say that views are, of course, not everything,
but I am worried that if we don’t talk
about it here on Two Minute Papers,
almost no one will talk about it. And these
works are so good, people have to know!
And if you agree, please spread the word on
these papers and show them to people you know!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!